en el vídeo anterior definimos esta
variable aleatoria x es una variable
aleatoria discreta que solo puede tener
un número finito de valores y la
definimos como el número de ejercicios
que puedo hacer en una semana y
calculamos el valor esperado de esta
variable aleatoria x que también podemos
denotar como la media de x usamos la
letra griega munch que se usa para
denotar la media de la población todo lo
que hicimos fue tomar la suma de las
probabilidades ponderadas de los
diferentes resultados y para esta
variable aleatoria en particular con
estas probabilidades específicas
obtuvimos un valor esperado o media de
2.1 lo que vamos a hacer ahora es
extender esta idea para medir la
dispersión así que vamos a pensar cuál
es la varianza de esta variable
aleatoria y podemos calcular la raíz
cuadrada de esto para encontrar la
desviación estándar la forma en la que
vamos a hacer esto se parece a lo que
hemos hecho anteriormente para calcular
la varianza la varianza de nuestra
variable aleatoria x lo que vamos a
hacer es calcular
la diferencia entre cada resultado y la
media elevada al cuadrado esa diferencia
y luego multiplicar la por la
probabilidad de dicho resultado por
ejemplo para este primer dato tenemos 0
menos 2.1 al cuadrado por la
probabilidad de 0 que es 0.1 sumamos 1
menos 2.1 al cuadrado multiplicado por
la probabilidad de tener 10 punto 15
luego tenemos la suma de dos menos 2.1
al cuadrado multiplicado por la
probabilidad de tener 2 que es 0.4 más 3
menos 2.1 al cuadrado por 0.25 y
finalmente sumamos 4 menos 2.1 al
cuadrado por 0.1 la diferencia de cada
resultado y la media la elevamos al
cuadrado y la multiplicamos por la
probabilidad de ese resultado 2.1 al
cuadrado por punto 1 el primer término
más uno por menos 2.1 nos queda menos
1.1 al cuadrado
si tenemos menos punto 1 por menos punto
1 nos va a dar punto 0 1 que es 1.1 al
cuadrado por punto 15 esto es 2 menos
2.1 que es 0.1 al cuadrado que es punto
0 1 x punto 4 más esto es 3 menos 2.1 al
cuadrado nos da a punto 81 que
multiplicamos por punto 25 más 1.9 al
cuadrado por punto 1 el resultado de
todo esto es 1 punto 19
lo escribimos si queremos tener la
desviación estándar de esta variable
aleatoria x quede notaremos con la letra
griega sigma la desviación estándar para
la variable aleatoria x va a ser igual a
la raíz cuadrada de la varianza la raíz
cuadrada de 1.19 que es igual raíz
cuadrada de 1.19 y es aproximadamente
1.09
veamos si esto tiene sentido pongamos
esto en una recta numérica
tenemos el 0 1 2 3 y 4 tenemos un 10 %
de tener un 0 que dibujamos así la
altura de un 10 por ciento tenemos 15
por ciento de tener un 1 que dibujamos
así una y media veces más alto tenemos
40% de probabilidad de tener un 2 así
que la altura aquí es 4 tenemos un 25
por ciento de probabilidad de tener un 3
que dibujamos así
y tenemos un 10% de probabilidad de
tener un 4 que no dibujamos a la misma
altura que el primer dato
esta es una visualización de esta
distribución de probabilidad discreta no
dibuje el eje vertical pero esta altura
es punto 1 esta es punto 15 esta es
punto 25 y esta es punto 4 la media está
en 2.1 lo que tiene sentido porque
aunque esta variable aleatoria solo
tiene valores enteros podemos tener una
media que sea un valor no entero la
desviación estándar es 1.09 y 1.09 por
encima de la media nos acerca a 3.2 1.09
por debajo de la media nos acerca a 1
todo esto parece razonable la media
parece ser un indicador de la tendencia
central de esta distribución y la
desviación estándar parece ser una
medida decente de esta dispersión